Rent is due, you've got bills, and there’s
no sign of a pay check coming anytime soon.
So, maybe if you’re a government worker,
it's time to find a second job?
The Fairfax county school district outside
of Washington DC has a shortage of substitute
teachers.
And Fairfax County now has an excess of furloughed
government workers.
Problem, solution ... at least temporarily.
"About 20% of the population in the greater
dc area works for the federal government...this
local community saw an opportunity to do something
their people."
When the school district advertised the event,
it filled up to capacity within 24 hours.
The interest was so overwhelming that they
added a second, and then a third hiring day.
While it usually takes a few weeks to approve
new substitute teachers, these people will
all be processed and ready to work in just
a few days.
The school board says, it’s really the least
they can do.
"Our employees here realized that we have
a lot of workers in need....and give them
an opportunity to earn a paycheck."
"We've heard lots of teachers are thrilled
to have the influx of talent ... it will have
a positive effect on our students."
The shutdown could end at any time.
Many federal employees at the event said they're
doing ok for now, but in the meanwhile, they
want a contingency plan, and the whole situation
is disheartening.
"I endured the 2013 shutdown...this one's
a little more
frustrating because there's no discussion,
or very little discussion."
"I'm frustrated, because I think services
to the citizens are being compromised..."
Where the federal government is stuck in the
mud, its employees are moving on, and this
local government is stepping up to help them.